we have reached 160k
but as you all know that's not enough
and we are really thankful
and we show a lot of gratitude to those
that have donated but please keep
donating the best of days are these
first 10 days
emphasized in doing good deeds in these
10 days
along these last 10 days he would exert
himself in obedience to Allah to the
extent that he will go beyond his
capacity so let us not forget donating
as you know we need a message in
Shepherd's Bush we need a Masjid in this
West London Community because the
situation here is a very dire one as you
all know the mission is small there's
restrictions plays upon us and we need
more facilities to provide for the
Greater Community likewise to the
children likewise for the teenagers
likewise given that or elsewhere and
like Christ providing Arabic lessons and
more Creed based lessons all of this is
for the community at large and we hope
that you don't forget donating as you
know in these first 10 days
Deeds is something that we should focus
on